all this talk about all these sherlock
holmes
live-action adaptations yet
when the hell are we gonna get sherlock
holmes in the 22nd century
you guys didn't see that show did you no
one saw that [ __ ] i'm the only one who
saw that show
i was to tell people what the show's
about they resurrect sherlock holmes in
the future
it's animated it's great i saw a little
bit of it
yeah yeah everything's a little bit with
you john it is i saw the whole
thing dedicated hey we're gonna watch
in nola homes ebola homes
now where to begin my mother named
which leads me onto the second thing you
need to know a week ago i awoke
to find that my mother was missing oh no
heavens
my god
[Music]
it is
[Applause]
i must become something
[Music]
unexpected
[Music]
[Music]
she's our company
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
it always needs to change
[Applause]
[Music]
i think
wow that was quite a treat that was
fun yeah that was fun before we started
filming this
my notification bells on youtube alerted
me that honest trailers has covered mean
girls i was like that's an interesting
choice
and then when watching this trailer
halfway through is like
this is kind of like a teen movie from
the 2000s
i was thinking of that dickinson show
with haley steinfeld this whole time
because it had a similar vibe at least
in the ad campaign
in terms of like the amount of sherlock
holmes properties
this feels the most different right now
in the most
fresh here's the odd thing i thought
about this trailer it seems like there's
a lot of tones happening here you
got something that does kind of remind
me of like a good version of a 2000s
teen comedies you know you got this
teenager
millie bobby brown alone homes you got
this very personal
investigative storyline of are you
getting to go find my mother and then as
soon as her
this adventure just sits around this
like crazy adventure
it leads to romance uncovering other
mysteries yadda yadda yadda and henry
kavala sherlock holmes is the buffet
sherlock holmes oh definitely
i was kind of surprised how it didn't
seem like there's
much sherlock in this trailer the focus
has to be on anola
and she's the main character she's the
one we're introducing at the same time i
for some reason i was just expecting the
trailer to kind of hone in a little bit
more on henry cavill
and the fact that he is sherlock holmes
halfway through i was like wait a minute
is this one of those
like wacky adventure ones where she's
like
stumbling into revelations that other
people are coming to hurt
and being like are you in all homes like
that kind of vibe or is it
a detective thing and she's really
solving and figuring out cases you know
i didn't really get much of that
vibe which is what i associate in the
sherlock holmes world you know like
piecing the evidence together or is it
she's kind of
stumbling into certain situations i'm
saying right now this felt less sherlock
holmes and more shanghai nights
it does have that kind of vibe that's
what i meant by like
wacky kind of just stumbling into the
answers
yeah yeah yeah yeah my like bumbling
convenience
and i feel like that wouldn't be the
tone you would
want this just given the day and age
we're in but it would be nice to have
that cleared up because yeah it's like
the tone and the look and the cast like
everything looks so fun and energetic
yeah
uh i i just hope there's a reason that
this is a sherlock holmes thing
i couldn't 100 tell in this trailer if
the implication is that she is
just as brilliant as sherlock holmes is
and is just as capable of a detective or
if she just has her own set of
incredibly
well-developed skills or something like
that and yeah i mean her mom is missing
so i have
some kind of suspicion that there's
gonna have to be a sherlock holmes style
mystery but i couldn't tell yeah whether
it was gonna become one of those
mad cap adventure things or if it's
gonna be like a dedicated no no no we
have this one mystery we're gonna solve
and maybe this guy's coming along for
the journey because when sherlock and
mycroft come in it started to feel to me
like some kind of odd
quirky family thing and maybe we're
gonna get to know their relationship
because i don't know how much anola
homes if it all figures
into the actual stories if his sister
was even alluded to or not it's funny to
me because now it feels like we're
getting some kind of
biologic biographical expansion you know
on a character who doesn't actually
exist i couldn't 100 tell if she's just
supposed to be brilliant
or or if it's just more about her
spunkiness or something like that
because it has that like fourth wall
breaking and she's constantly talking to
you which
doesn't always suggest cleverness to me
when it comes to writing
at least in terms of like you know true
mystery and stuff like that
wanting to demonstrate all these tones
in this one like almost
three minute trailer i was a little bit
confused on what the actual
style of the movie is because it's when
the credits came
up yeah it feels more like it should be
a series it does
when the credits came up with like the
pictures and really feeling like a teen
movie
i was like this is kind of jarring yeah
yeah a little bit
i was charmed but also jarring yeah what
i'm worried about just because of again
this trailer and
and this is again pretty fresh as an
idea to me i don't know a lot about the
history of how this movie
got made but i almost wonder if
we're gonna have an issue in that like
if the movie's just great it's
then that's all that matters really but
i feel like there could be some level of
confusion for people being like is
sherlock holmes gonna figure into this
is he gonna be a big part of it from
this trailer kind of looks like he's
gonna be a
side character who you know is
significant but not a huge part of the
main plot
and so are you going to get people who
were taken aback by that are you going
to get people who are coming in
still expecting a lot of sherlock even
though he's not named after him and
would it have been worth it
at that point to just create a new uh
brilliant sleuth female character
i will say though millie bobby brown
getting a chance to rock her
as what i i believe is her actual accent
yeah
the only two things i've seen her
stranger things in godzilla
and to see her here where i'm like her
personality
really shines and she does feel like a
commanding lead
yeah and i do love how she doesn't
just seem like oh you're female sherlock
you know like yeah it feels like a very
different
character yeah yeah and as much as i'm
unclear i'm also like
that seems like it could have potential
yeah exactly definitely has this like
feminine quality to it uh the whole
trailer vibe
yet it's written and directed by two
guys
that's interesting i could hear
something wrong with that i i've just
kind of
been worse i'm kind of surprised i
wouldn't expect like a female writer at
least for some reason i could just see
them on the couch being like we could
sell that
that moment where they had the idea you
know and i mean sure and i'm sure you
know a lot of uh
you know female talent was employed to
make the movie but it is yeah funny
a little bit funny for it being in the
homes investigation
universe i would like it to be more than
kind of like because the last half kind
of made it feel
a bit like a wacky adventure and not
enough like
true detective qualities because it
seems like she's supposed to start off
as kind of
she's a teenager she's kind of goofy
yeah she's nothing like her brother and
they
run around the edges a little bit yeah
then she's supposed to kind of grow into
her own and even there's a crack that
sherlock makes in this trailer
about like no she's actually i didn't
quite catch it the children were so fast
she's like she's actually kind of
intelligent or something the impression
i was getting is that she seems like
someone who
who couldn't solve this or be a proper
hero and then she'll kind of grow
into her own and then prove against all
odds
that she could save the day yeah and
that she could be a hero and
maybe the brilliance of the home's
reasoning ability had something to do
with their mom and i really feel like
henry cavill could pull off a sherlock
holmes
and if this does well it would be cool
to get a sequel where it is like millie
bobby brown
and henry cavill the duo i've always
wanted and then we can get him actually
like doing some bare knuckle boxing and
taking opium frame rate
and it'll do the the arm [ __ ] like
possible
he'll actually beat someone down it's
gonna be awesome
all right guys well what'd you think of
this trailer will you be watching it
this september probably
not much coming out all right guys well
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell leave your thoughts
down below about the trailer last but
not least
adelia chamberlain adelia
you know how much i love the hell out of
you
and i was like out of anyone here who
reminds me the most
of and nola holmes it's gotta be atelier
yeah
so yeah tied it in adelia you know if
you investigate her name oh
you could find out what it really means
a stands for
ambitious ooh d stands for
do do gooder you're a yeah e
is for equality because that's what she
fights for
l for lovely which you are
i for intelligent because
obviously and a for
amazing because you're amazing
adelia delia break out of your chamber
and go into the lane the lane find your
lane
of of uh deductive uh murdering
republicans
murdering republicans yeah
you know i'm sure you'll be brilliant at
it
i'm not saying i want that i i i think
that's what you want i think
yeah i think you need to kind of climb
just kidding
republicans are number one they yeah
make america
[Music]
saved